[Musique]
si tu passes centrale puisqu'elle se
trouve effectivement au carrefour de
plusieurs aujourd'hui livraison de
bâtiments il ya donc la place du lieu de
vie aujourd'hui très animé qui accueille
beaucoup d'étudiants au quotidien vous
avez effectivement le bâtiment
d'enseignement effectivement de la
physique inauguré aujourd'hui donc cette
place sera en permanence une place de
croisement d'animation des étudiants ce
qui est un pur no 1 un élément est
évidemment centrale d'animation des
quartiers que nous produisons sur sur le
quartier manière plus générale nous
avons aussi livré très récemment un peu
plus loin à côté de l'école centrale
mais aussi de le lsd comme naturelles
supérieure
les premiers logements familiaux au rez
de chaussée des bientôt vont arriver les
premiers commerces du quartier de
moulins qui feront évidemment le
complément à ce qui vient d'être livrée
sur le quartier des écoles
polytechniques juste l'autre côté qui
sont déjà une
les premiers lieux de vie très actif en
ce moment sur sur le quartier sur
lesquels les gens évidemment s'appuie
pour pour vivre au quotidien donc la vie
s'anime largement aujourd'hui sur notre
notre campus urbain et cette place est
un nouvel exemple de l'animation
complète que nous réalisons juste
derrière moi vous pouvez voir également
évidemment les vestiges d'une villa
gallo romaine
on a souhaité avec y compris les
habitants de d'orsay mais aussi des
associations qui travaillent autour de
ces vestiges
on a souhaité en accord avec donc
l'ensemble de ces personnes associées
maintenir ces vestiges à ciel ouvert
comme vous le voyez on les préservant
ils vont être restaurés très bientôt
c'est à dire à l'été prochain
et ça sera un lieu pour nous à la fois
de de raconter compris un passé sur le
plateau le pen le plateau était malgré
tout ce qu'on pouvait en dire était un
plateau est évidemment occupé il ya très
longtemps
ces vestiges gallo romaine et pour nous
et symbolique aussi du passé et
évidemment d'une ville du futur que
qu'on voit se développer tous les jours
sous nos yeux
[Musique]